Drake is the best rapper alive I means
everything I've been in a game over ten
years
instrumental and my growth as a person
and the player on the football field I
was in the locker room Odell Beckham and
I remember one time he's playing some
Drake song I'm in the corner I'm like
Shazam and Emma this is amazing and then
I found out like you can't get this
anywhere Drake's just sent it to Odell
and he has like songs are gonna be
released in ten years on his phone
already and I'm just not in that clique
and I never will be and I came to terms
with that so one day I was a nice guy
and Drake
we took a champagne shot together of me
Christian McCaffrey and other guys it
was late I am so far gone
October zone where did we go wrong haha
yeah so far going that was the first
album was that Houston line of aigis all
of that successful was a big hit I still
play in my everyday life right now and
it's still like my theme song but yeah
so far gonna continue it's crazy
it's dope